[Music]
so you don't make big huge action genre
movies where people fly off buildings
you make
movies that are in some ways more
imaginative when everything gets big
it's not going to be fun anymore
and i've always had the most fun in the
small independent films it was made for
very little money
and um it was very much it sort of felt
like a family affair
i don't try to identify exactly the
workings when it's working well
it's it's uh like uh falling in love you
don't think too hard about it you just
fall and what's fabulous is that year
after year
independent pictures still go out and do
great box offices
hello i'm charles champlin and a lot of
us who love the movies
believe that some of the very best of
them come these days from the
independent sector
made outside the major studios with
their huge budgets and their timidities
the indies more often made on a
shoestring can be tough
outspoken outrageous courageous original
and terrifically affecting and they are
today here in the beverly hills hotel
the independent feature project west
an organization of some 2300 independent
filmmakers distributors and supporters
is handing out its annual spirit awards
and the nominated work is high proof
just how important independent films
have become in the market
there's the grifters mr mrs bridge wild
at heart
to sleep with anger henry portrait of a
serial killer
others less well-known so far like
lightning over braddock
and from abroad the cook the thief his
wife and her lover and australian jane
campions
sweetie and we're about to meet some of
these very spirited
independent filmmakers my name is
charles burnett i'm the director and
writer of sleep with anger and the
film's been nominated for independent
spirit awards and and
in a number of categories and we're
quite pleased and happy i'm tasha
campbell
it's reggie helden i'm a
king i'm kid warrington exeter harris
for robin harris play
and the movie is house party
as far as this nomination deal i'm i'm
i'm
surprised you know i'm incredibly
honored i'm with stillman from director
of metropolitan ms carolyn farina who is
nominated for best actress
hi i do all the talking
well i'm bruce davidson and i'm
nominated for a spirit award
for a long time companion okay i'm
michael rooker i'm the
actor i played henry and here's the uh
all of my other two actors in the
in the movie my other two actors in this
movie was
tommy tony i'm annette punacello
wrong movie no i'm tom toles and this is
tracy arnold tracy arnold my sister in
the movie sister in the movie
who's behind you uh oh rick paul rick
paula victim
set decorator uh props art director and
production designer and i am
unfortunately for everyone is john
mcnaughton uh director
co-writer co-produced steve jones
co-producer
music composer i'm ben lang and i play
the kosher catering
plot against harry well we grew up
together in a little town in alabama
and we said one day we was gonna make a
movie together we all slept in the same
bed
let's stop all the front y'all
personally they couldn't pay me enough
money to work with this guy again
it's a family atmosphere here it was a
little rough in the beginning you know
a whole lot of different ways
transforming into one but as you can see
we got the pops here got the two fathers
here
got someone with a mother here even
though she don't look the part and right
here we got the daughter
not the illegitimate son we got the
prodigal son right here
well i i think what happened is i got a
again a really a good cast that
identified very strongly with the rose
you know
and we tried to make it an ensemble
group um
where everyone was a participant and
that like no star like dang i mean danny
was very great because he
he you know it was just another carriage
and the whole idea was to get the story
across not any individuals
and so we all worked for that end and he
let us put our two cents in
yes we could say what we wanted to do i
was a female lead what does that mean i
stayed alive through the whole film so
normal heart was a little scary
uh by the time i got to long time
companion i had gotten over a lot of my
fear
and it's been both of them have been
i guess the two most rewarding
experiences i've had as an actor
there was a lot of me in there
and just reading the script i just kind
of knew it was
it just it just all sort of blowed you
know and then when we did the rehearsals
and everything it all seemed
to come together very nicely there's a
lot of negative attitude about the
subject matter metropolitan is a comedy
about a group of socialites in manhattan
and a lot of people didn't like the sort
of uh rich kid milieu the idea of film
about that
but um once the film was done we started
getting really positive faster reactions
so
the um we're really delighted with the
reviews but we weren't totally shocked
we were open for that
we did the movie for about 125 000 and
all local people out of chicago
everybody worked real hard it was almost
everyone's very first feature
and
you know wherever wherever that movie
had gone
if it had been seen in the least a
little bit we'd all been very satisfied
i'm surprised every day the more
attention it gets i didn't think anybody
could see the film
or distribute it and each step has been
a sort of a little miracle
i was as much surprised as everyone else
has been the nominee
the uh a matter of fact i had completely
forgotten about the existence of the
picture
because it was on the shelf for 20 years
it
came about just wanting to do a film
that says something particular about
the black experience that we can all
share in you know and just sort of
help to break down some of the barriers
and things that um
uh you know i think sort of has been
created largely by hollywood and it's
sort of myths about black people
no because we're not all involved in
drugs and crime and stuff like that you
know we're
members of the human race and i think we
should be betrayed as such
i think the film and the actors really
wanted to do that to do that
well the oscar nomination cost a lot of
money and so you know we spent that much
we wanted to get it
uh but no uh yeah we're really surprised
it's very hard for an independent film
to get noticed
by the academy independence is a state
of mind
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is there anyone having lunch here today
or anywhere else for that matter
who hasn't made a film isn't making a
film isn't planning to make a film
or isn't married to or sleeping with
someone who has
bought or sold an idea for an
outline based on something adapted from
an incident derived from a suggestion
made reported on or overheard at a
previous lunch
i doubt it i was on a bus the other day
in new york
and i asked for a transfer and i started
looking at it to check the transfer
points and the bus driver said to me
don't bother it's already optioned
and i saw him later at the golden globes
and he won
what the hell is going on and what's
going on
here i mean isn't this exactly what i
predicted
lights cameras funeral music
expensive tables with silverware
remember just a few years ago when this
once
modest event took place in a now
justifiably defunct restaurant
in an unfashionable section of los
cienega where dressed in cut off jeans
and tank tops
we few we happy few gorged on swill
and rock gut and basically ogled each
other for a couple of hours before
giving out cheap trinkets to
celebrate the making of films many of
which cost
less than one of joel silver's cufflinks
not anymore just a few restaurants and
hotels later and here we are crawling
rung by rung up the ladder of
respectability
to the attic in which live the three
weird sisters of show business
publicity celebrity and glitz
[Applause]
why me
it's like uh staring out into a sea of
faces
as the covered wagons draw in and see
who the survivors are
year by year like chickens delivering
eggs
you struggle against the odds to deliver
the
the new the bold the innocent the fresh
my admiration goes out to you
because it isn't easy as we know to keep
that
dream fresh doug mcarthur said
you're as young as your hope and you're
as old as your despair
i urge you to keep on dreaming
and never never give the bastards on the
other side the benefit of the doubt
i was desperately looking for an
independent filmmaker and
and stumbled into one on my table
i
so i have this and i'll be taking this
home with me
um all the people uh
i see here tonight um there are some
independent minds in here who are doing
quite well
who are not on the fringe who are inside
and i'm proud of their individuality
and the way they approach their business
the battle of the independent is not
with the studio
the perception can never be that they
don't want you
this is this is clearly a business that
makes room for good people
the battle that exists is with
yourselves and it's
with myself and it's our ability
to face the facts to face reality
the reality is if you're good
they cannot keep you out
you've heard me say they a lot and i
wish i could take it out on this fucking
speech because
i don't i don't really mean they
um there is no there is no they there is
no
covert see is there oliver is there a
is there a secret group keeping us down
the independent down
there is no group the they is you
the problem that exists for you is the
same
that exists for me it's the same that
exists for andy
and it's the same that it exists for
michael ovitch
because god knows i ask him every time
we talk
where is the good material where are the
scripts
you know for a business that cloaks
itself in creativity
it's an almost monotonous question that
we go through
it's the one constantness business that
never goes away
and the magic of reading a script alone
at night
after having waited through 50
and suddenly the pages start to turn
faster than the page before
you find yourself rushing through hoping
beyond hope
that the last 30 pages are as good
as the first 90.
you find yourself running in to wake up
your wife
your husband your lover you wake them up
out of a dead sleep
and you tell them that you've just read
something that you want to make a part
of your life
they usually roll over and say jesus
okay okay okay okay i'll read it
that when that happens that is a product
of hard work
simple and fair and i will not quit
until i find
the person who's done that work and try
to be a part of the dream with him
the great script i think of the great
script in terms of
maybe a fishing term i think of it as
power bait
i think you can catch anybody in this
town
unless of course there's some other
agenda at work
and that i can never understand because
if you aren't to make movies
for any other reason than to make them
to be proud of them
i won't ask you to leave the room but i
would suggest that you'll be bored by
this
kind of old-fashioned talk this is the
sixth year of the independent
spirit awards once again the community
of independent filmmakers gathers to
honor and pay tribute to its own
the awards go to independent films
defined for the purposes of this award
as films made outside the development
and production apparatus of the studio
system
which have been nominated by a diverse
committee of filmmakers writers
and independents it's an honor just to
be nominated
well that's what it says
the nominees are then voted on by the
entire ifp membership
some of them actually see the films
others use ouija boards and neurology
the ballots were tabulated and i know
you want to know this
by kpmg pete marwick's
dave merritt and tom nosbaum and they'll
be appearing in love letters at the
cannon theater
to present the awards for best
cinematography
terry garr and carol king
um we congratulate all of the nominees
for best cinematography
and they are boyin bazzelli for king of
new york
peter deming for house party fred elms
for
wild at heart emir mokri for
life is cheap but toilet paper is
expensive how true that is
and robert young for the truth about
harry
and the winner is
okay um oh okay
the winner is fred elms wild at heart
[Music]
wow baby i got a surprise for you what
hey my snakeskin jacket
thanks baby did i ever tell you that
this year jacket represents a similar my
individuality and my belief in personal
freedom
50 000 times i got us a room at the cape
fear and guess what powerman is playing
at the
hurricane stabbing and steer
thank you it's um it's a pleasure to
to receive this honor from a group of
people who really
make the kinds of films that i you know
love to go see in the movie theaters
i i guess we should thank kodak and
panavision also for for helping to make
wild at heart possible
um i want to thank
my director who who gave me the
inspiration to do some good work
but really i want to thank the crew who
who don't get up here and don't receive
the awards and
always stand behind the camera the
people who
set the lights and move the camera
around for us and
do the makeup and the hair and the
styling and the whole art department who
who really make me you know look best
thank you
[Music]
here to present the award for best
screenplay
are miley maitland and mario van
peebles
for the best screenplay are charles
burnette to sleep with anger
john mcnaughton and richard fire of
henry portrait of a serial killer
and last an alan moyle for pump up the
volume
michael romer for the plot against terry
and with stillman for metropolitan
and the okay i'm winner is that her
voice
charles burnett can sleep with anger
[Applause]
i have to know who is in my house
you invited me yes i did
but only if you are a good man
[Applause]
a friend are you a friend harry
like that boy next door playing his horn
if he was a friend he would stop
irritating people
but if he stops practicing
he wouldn't be perfect at what he does
someday
i want you to leave charles burnett
congratulations not to sleep with anger
quite a struggle to get the film made it
was yeah um
how long were you involved with trying
to find i think it took about two and a
half years to get
financing uh-huh has it found audiences
to some extent
and not really i i think it's a matter
of um
distribution and trying to get the money
to advertise and so forth
uh there's certainly the audience then
but perhaps the spirit award will
will help and bring more attention on
the film which is hopefully yeah really
here to present the award for best
supporting actor are m
emmett walsh and rosanna arquette
the nominees for best supporting actor
are william defoe for wild at heart
bruce davison for long time companions
robin harris for house party
ben lange for the prop the plot against
terry
and tom talls for henry portrait of a
serial killer
[Applause]
and the winner is bruce davison
long time companion
[Music]
i feel that something's happening
in my body now i'm not talking about
john
talking about me i feel like something
is
stalking me i know you think i'm being
melodramatic
did you sleep with someone else
no well then you can't have aids because
i haven't touched another man since we
were in key west
1980 unless you can pick it up on a
toilet seat i don't know how long it's
going to take to germany it's not going
to take four years
incubate your bait
did you sleep with john no i did not
sleep with him and then there's nothing
to worry
about my side of the bed was soaking
this morning well so is mine
because it's summer in the summer it is
hot we don't have
air conditioning
what
i'm not a child stop talking to me like
i'm a child
like i know congratulations bruce
davidson thank you
this is at least the second time you've
been honored for this isn't it um
yes actually the golden globes and the
national film critics and the new york
critics it must be a great satisfaction
to you
it's quite a ride every every uh step
has been uh
miraculous but uh like i said
before i really think uh it's not me
alone that's carrying this
it's wonderful to be a part of it
here to present the award for best
supporting actress
are barbara hershey and john glover
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for best supporting actress
are tracy arnold for henry portrait of a
serial killer
ethel ehler for to sleep with anger
tisha campbell house party
aj johnson for house party
cheryly ralph to sleep with anger
and the winner is sheryl lee ralph
to sleep with anger
[Music]
it wasn't for people who write and
direct
like charles burnett i wouldn't be able
to have this chance to stand up here
accept this award from you
for my good work because you wouldn't
get to see it because so many still
don't believe
i'm a human being i exist in the
industry
i love my art and when i say i i mean
all of my peers who are so
talented who would accept it just like
me if they could only get the job
if they could only get the script if
they could only be seen
as thinking feeling human being
females who just happen to be women of
color
in my case black thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in your acceptance speech you made a
wonderful statement about how proud you
were as a
black woman of black actress to have
this award
yeah well it's important to me because
you know i accept the award for so many
of my
peers who if they were only the scripts
if they were only
thought of more often they'd be up there
they'd be accepting more awards
but nobody's thinking about them
nobody's thinking about us they're not
writing the stories and we're not
getting the chance
and it is 1991 and they can't name me
one leading black female dramatic
actress right now
they can't name me one because there
isn't one and because nobody has taken
the time
to develop one so one for me and all of
my my peers
i accept the award gladly
here to present the award for best first
feature is annette benning
nominees for best first feature are
house party director reginald hudlin
producer warrington hudlun
lightning over braddock producer and
director tony
buba
metropolitan producer director with
stillman
the natural history of parking lots
director everett
lewis producer aziz gazal
and twister director michael almereda
producer
velande schultz-keel
and the winner is metropolitan
director
so you had a trust fund and pieces are
beginning to fall into place
i don't have one anymore well that's
less important
i mean um so sociologically i i mean
what's important is having grown up with
the assumption of material security
it explains a lot hi carl
you had no cards why'd you call i felt
like it
playing strip poker with an exhibition
that somehow takes the challenge away
i think that the the truth of making
independent films is we don't really
start out
wanting to make independent films that
we we'd prefer to
graduate from college and be given the
chance to or graduate from maybe high
school or elementary school and start
making films
without having go to go the independent
route but
um when we do when we are obliged to go
the independent route we often find that
there are many many
great things about it that we we learned
to sort of to love all the problems and
and all the opportunities and we want to
stay doing it the same way
um i'm very grateful to new line cinema
for ignoring the salt lake city reviews
before they bought the film
and um thank you very much
[Applause]
here to present the award for best
director is
andy garcia
thank you uh i'm truly honored to be
here
i'm invited again next year kevin you
cease to amaze me you're still the
toughest i can follow and i'll follow
you anywhere
cheryl lee i'll kiss you anytime i don't
care who comes to see it
the nominees for best picture are
charles burnett to sleep with that i'm
sorry the
nominees for for the best director
uh charles burnett stop laughing to
sleep with anger
reginald hudlin house part
john mcnaughton henry portrait of a
serial killer
alan moyle pump up the volume
[Applause]
martin loma the plot against harry
the winner is
charles burnett to sleep with anger
that is a damn lie and you know it
every time father asks you to do
something you either half ass do it or
you run off and hide mama asked you to
turn the dirt in her garden and you told
her with your
smart ass self that you wanted a father
dead junior to do it
every time somebody asks you to do
something you say tell junior to do it
boy you ought to grow up
i told you about calling me boy see
i ain't no boy see you and daddy got a
bad habit of calling me boy
you call me boy in front of my wife yeah
you think i'm gonna fix the roof yeah
huh
i hope the whole damn thing blows off
and it pours down rain
how to break your damn neck yeah
yeah i'm leaving don't even call me when
the shoe falls cause all he ever did for
me was trying to run my life
i'm so sick of people trying to run my
life you know
big brother what's my name you
dumb ass it's big brother my name is sam
samuel um
this gives me another opportunity to
thank a number of people again
uh um the same people of course
especially mr president and katie
chubbin
uh all the actors and mr tom rothman and
goldwyn for picking up the film and no
one else
did um um
but but you know like i said there there
are a number of people behind the camera
who are very wonderful and special who
who uh believe in the film and it made
it easier for me to direct the film
and um i really like to thank them and
thank you
again thank you
here to present the award for best actor
is tim robbins
[Applause]
asked to define his craft actor alec
guinness once said i tried to do
as little as possible
funny guy um
nominees for best actor are danny glover
to sleep with anger
martin priest the plot against harry
chris reed house party
somebody better give them something
michael rooker henry portrait of a
serial killer
scared the shit out of me and christian
slater and pump up the volume
the winner is danny glover to sleep
[Music]
mr glover you're also one of the
producers of to sleep with anger yeah i
was an executive producer
yeah yeah so how did that come about i
mean you just obviously fell in love
with that material i guess
yeah i mean i'm really it's not the
easiest material to fall in love with
yeah you know i mean
it's just some you just feel something
and i i think what happened
initially was that the film just moved
me gutturally in some sort of way yeah
reminded me of something and it wanted
me to
and some someone gave me the incentive
to find out more about what i didn't
know
what was this what was this feeling that
i was feeling what's upon me this time
why did this thing
the script or this story tend to linger
with me in some sort of way and that was
uh
really interesting part because it's
part reality and part almost
surrealism isn't it it is quite tough
tough thing for an actor to get hold of
i should think well i
think you know you never you never play
the realistic i mean the surrealism you
never
look at that yeah i think that like any
any character you take on he has certain
needs
uh he has certain adjustments you know
there's certain things that he wants you
know
and and and whatever the character is
here to present the award for best
actors are
laura dern and edward james olmos
the nominees for best actress are
marry alice to sleep with anger
[Applause]
esther balant and ball bale jumper
carolyn farina in metropolitan
angelica houston for the grifters
and joanne woodward for mr and mrs
bridge
[Applause]
and the winner is angelica
cornball clown pictures commission
salesman it's all up front
you're working some angle and don't tell
me you're not because i wrote the book
you're one to talk you're still running
playback money for the mob
that's me that's who i am you were never
cut out for the rackets wrong
you aren't tough enough
not as tough as you huh how'd you get
that punch in the stomach roy
i tripped on a chair get off the grift
roy
why
you haven't got the stomach for it
wow this is great
independence usually gets me in trouble
so i'm very relieved to be here among
you independents
um and also to being part of the
grifters
um i'd like to thank stephen frears
martin scorsese and barbara defina
our fabulous distributors at miramax the
innovative harvey and bob weinstein
tony howard bodie boatwright susan
geller
and my special thanks to kevin costner
for not being a woman
and uh for those of you who are
interested or
or might like to pass by table 2 on
your way out of here this evening you
can see my wig for the sequel for
drifters
also an independent movie i thank you
all very much
here to present the award for the best
foreign film is
isabella russellini
[Applause]
thank you the category of best foreign
film
was created to honor those film which
express
an independent spirit but which are a
foreign organization
or our co-production the nominees
are black rain directed by
shoei imamura siti
city of sadness director hoshei hoshen
who
the cook the thief is a lot of tea
ages that i cannot say his wife
and her lover by peter green away
freeze die and come to life directed by
vitaly
kanewski
and sweetie by jane campion
and the winner is sweetie
director jane champion
[Applause]
i'm coming in surprise
what are you doing here you know you're
not allowed you broke the bloody window
i'm really mad at you
it wouldn't open okay it was really
stiff
of course it was it was locked
yeah well i couldn't get it to open
why sweetie says that you're a really
nice lady
who's he my producer
bob mckay okay bob you've stopped taking
your medication haven't you
yeah well bob and i are really going to
walk through some doors okay we're
really getting it together
tell him to take off louie's jacket
you can't stay you know that oh yeah
well if it wasn't so late we'd go
you know but i just wanted to see you
and say hi there
jane campion congratulations on on
sweetie uh
your your next film also has one at the
cannes film festival this year i think
was that the
venice festival actually won the jury
prize angel at my table
yeah how did you
get sweetie going in australia i mean as
an independent film was it tough to find
financing or backing for it no i think
it was quite tough but i mean i think
compared to some stories i don't think
it was
nearly as difficult i think the crunch
moment
was i was sent to talk to some and
likely investors
and they asked me to tell the story
because they didn't think there was a
story there and that they heard it was
funny and they didn't think it was
couldn't see what was humorous about it
oh my god this is a tall order so
i started to tell them the story and as
i was watching them they were looking a
little bit bored so i sort of went and
that's it you know sort of caught a way
through and they were so relieved i
think that it was um
you know that much of the story or that
and they just sort of i know they had
this feeling of wanting to impress me in
the end and sort of say okay we'll
put the money in was what which is what
they happened
ladies and gentlemen here to present the
award for best feature is jody foster
the best feature
uh the grifters produced by martin
scorsese robert harris and james payton
henry a portrait of a serial killer
producer john mcnaughton lisa deadman
stephen h jones
[Applause]
the plot against harry producer robert
young
and an old professor of mine michael
romer
pump up the volume producer rupert
harvey and sandy stern
and to sleep with anger producer
caldecott well
katie chubb thomas burns and darren
scott
and the winner is
the grifters martin score stacey robert
here exchange maiden miramax
you're right really you're roy's mother
that's impossible not quite but
i'm not sure who you are like tree was
it
i'm roy's friend yes i imagine you're
lots of people's friends
oh oh of course
now that i see you in the light you're
plenty old enough to be roy's mother
aren't we all play nice don't fight
darling you're gonna be all right
sure i am what am i doing here
marty couldn't be here so i'd like to
thank you all on on his behalf uh he'd
know would also like to thank stephen
frears uh donald westlake
peggy ryski all the people who really
worked hard and made the movie the cast
and the
crew and our angelic i'm we're all so
thrilled
and this is marty's first real
recognition as a producer and i want you
to know this award is really going to be
very special to him
thank you
robert harris and jim payne
congratulations on
on the grifters thank you uh was it a
hard film to get going i'm just kind of
curious
uh it took a long time we walked around
for
a year or so without much attention
being paid to us
it was marty that really got it going i
mean it would have been impossible
without
let's be blunt his clout and uh
his ability to just go to people and and
say we want to do this then
and from the beginning he said we're
going to get it done what was the
problem that it seemed too tough i mean
that was it it's the same story it was
turned down i think in every major
studio
it was in development for three minutes
at disney
uh not not their kind of material i
think
the way we made it anyway uh but it was
very it's very hard material the ending
was
especially difficult for people to
accept they want people wanting to
change the end
yeah and it's so that was that was it
that was what the movie was about
a lot of people who know jim thompson
and know his work
people in the studios when we first had
it they said they admired him
but they just could never get it made
congratulations grifters
thank you ladies and gentlemen this
concludes the first half of this
afternoon's program
five years ago you really do need to
form a family on films there's no
other way to do it i mean and to be
honest for me it was
well yes tough maybe but but um very
gripping and the kind of
the kind of stuff you love to play the
independent award is really
important to me because
nobody would make this film independent
films are right in there with the best
of studio pictures and
so i think it's really part of the
community now i always feel like they're
more from the heart